okay John so today I have in my hands as
the the sony alpha a 900 DSLR tell me a
popular yeah this is a this is a direct
competition or i think with the prosumer
it's a professional-grade canon and
nikon cameras it's 24 megapixels it's a
full-frame chip which means that the
image sensor is the same size as a
35-millimeter piece of film you're going
to see the entire focal length of your
lens so if you're shooting at 24
millimeters wide you're going to see
everything on the sensor or other
cheaper DSLRs have cropped image sensors
we're gonna want something like this to
get the most out of this awesome lens
that's only sent us the carl zeiss
playing RT yeah they said that so that
that lens doesn't come with this camera
iceland's does not come with this camera
I don't know if this lens comes with any
camera it's so it's about three thousand
dollars also if I could throw it on the
camera that I use every day I would okay
it's super sharp it's a nice mid-range
zoom carl zeiss make some really cool
glass so okay so you you can't put it
all the camera that you use everyday
what use that Cannon right is a canon
mark three okay that's what we should
move over a wired com yeah and the the
mark 3 doesn't can't take the girls
excellence it can't not yet okay but
someday someday i think carl zeiss just
announced a ze amount where they'll be
able to put on a 50 millimeter an 85
millimeter lens I think it was coming up
sometime soon okay cool okay so your
shoot you're out so you're out like
cheating with sky uh how does it compare
will say like your canon or even like an
icon like it the d3 or something that's
a great question because when i took
this camera out I did what am I my
favorite things to do with digital
cameras and shoot in really low light
this camera boasts a really high iso
6400 so that means you can shoot in
really really really really love you can
practically see in the dark with this
lens open up all the way another thing
is that this this body has a built-in
image stabilization it's going to give
you about four more stops of light when
you're she
which means you'll be able to handhold
this independent dark situations so it
doesn't have night vision but it's close
it's pretty close so I took it out to a
friends DJ night and shot around in a
really dark club and the results were
pretty pretty good noisy but usable when
yeah i did it i saw i saw one of the
prints like the one that probably
showing right now it's it's got a little
bit noisy specially in the colors of
darker oh yeah the shadows the shadows
yeah this yes a little bit noisy I one
thing I wasn't too excited about is the
focusing in a low light I found that it
was really tough to get a handle on what
what the lenses pointed at even things
that were slightly out of focus just
because this Carl Zeiss glasses on it
made it look really cool none of the
buttons are back late which I don't know
is a huge issue that's bit of a problem
yeah it's a bit of a problem if they're
gonna have so many if you are already
invested in Nikon and Canon glass i'd
say probably stick with their DSLRs
they're really nice this costs about as
much as a pro canon or nikon DSLR lens
and ends and the body ok um together i
think it's a great combination ok we
have to see what the kit lens is if n
there's not computer there's not gonna
be kid owns well hope you have your mind
says hi this is the archos five and it
is so shiny that it comes with its own
polishing cloth I still don't think I've
gotten all the thumb prints off of this
thing alright let's wake it up and show
the nice people what what an amazing
beautiful video screen this thing yeah i
mean its outstanding 4.8 inches it's
pretty big ok so this is my big you look
at this and you might think i've seen a
certain phone that looks like this but a
little bit not really anything to do
with the phone this basically just plays
video music photos you have it on did i
mention a really big gorgeous beautiful
high-resolution you know what the exact
size of these player is
if I hold it like this I sort of feel
like I'm looking at a large screen TV
that I'm just you know far away from it
right perspective okay that's not
working um it has a linux operating
system which you know you look at around
it actually looks well look at that it
looks nice and I Linux i think is
totally moot on this i don't even know
why you bring it up because it's the
only element is real I mean basically
it's you've got a menu here you can get
six to three menus house browse the web
you can check your email right or you
can play videos music or look at slide
shows but let's talk about the price
okay is you know 350 bucks this is
basically a 60 gig hard drive right with
a screen on it and a couple of outputs
for hdmi and other other kinds of video
outputs if you get an optional accessory
it's not the most usable thing for no
for browsing the web the plane catch up
and when it's your the main way that you
interact with a media tablet and you
still have the experience of the iphone
that's it's totally different so that's
your expectation and you're totally are
going to be a little bit slightly
disappointed right when you're double
clicking when you're touching when you
expect to zoom in with multi-touch and
it doesn't happen and you're like what
was kind of sucks yeah Apple has
completely brainwashed us into expecting
certain gestures right-to-work certain
ways like the pinch or the double tap or
what have you right this is sort of
close but not quite there right alright
so bottom line it's an elegantly
designed device and did I mention it has
a really drop dead gorgeous screen I
love the screen you just can't stop you
mentioned there a couple times
you